oh there there we go there are also a
handful of puzzles in here that just
don't quite communicate themselves super
super awesome
like I think that one was a decent
example of one where it's like okay
you've kind of got a general sense of
your goal but the rationale behind that
is are you kidding me
it's like okay I kind of want to make my
way in this direction but the eye the
sense that it's like okay you want to go
up the chain or you want to get to the
chain because the chain will do this
thing the chain will the chain is going
to raise that platform like the fact
that the chain would raise that platform
was not communicated by the puzzle at
all such because if you just you're just
moving towards the chain and then you
get to the chain and all of a sudden the
chain raises the platform if I go okay I
guess that's what we were doing whereas
you've got a lot of the better built
puzzles where it's like okay I want to I
want to lower the drawbridge and there
are some things that clearly are going
to be involved in lowering the
drawbridge or that would believably be
triggers in lowering the drawbridge I
think a good example like a really good
example that we passed not too long ago
was the bombs on the on the walkway it's
like you look around the walkway and you
get this high up view looking down and
from that view you can see that the
pillar supporting the walkway is kind of
cracked and broken and then either
through exploration after that or
through exploration you've already done
you find the bombs and it's like okay I
need to bomb I need to bomb the pillar
in order to drop the walkway well in
order to light the bombs I'm going to
need fire and if you're looking around
then you find the you find the
chandelier and now you've got the three
parts that you need like you know that
these are the three things that you need
to combine and so you just need to
figure out how to get them together and
I think that's a really you know that's
a great example of a really well done
puzzle it's like here's the parts you
know you have a sense of what your of
what your actual goal is and you have
pieces that are involved in that that
makes sense as a part of as a part of
that and so you get to go through the
process of then bringing them together